this weekend hey I'm on this weekend is
Mexican Independence Day weekend and
there will be celebrations across town
including at the award-winning topless
female review fantasy at the Luxor and
here to tell us more about their special
tribute This is Lorena Pearl welcome to
the show
gracias yeah
for having me this show is on
finest it's amazing 23 years going on 23
years fantasy at the Luxor eight
beautiful dancers we got Murray we got
Shea matosh we got I mean you have me
Latina Mexicans yes and we're
celebrating Mexican Independence Day so
why not you guys are award-winning show
right year after year we're nominated
once again for best of Las Vegas and
we've won about dozen Awards now and
we're so grateful we keep winning we
just keep moving we keep changing the
show around that's what's amazing about
fantasy we change it all the time Las
Vegas loves you you love Las Vegas so
tell me more about this weekend the
special performance tomorrow night well
tomorrow night I will be performing a
classic Mariachi called La chariada can
you say that
Fernandez okay okay
there's a classic by Linda Ronstadt that
she redid when she was younger and she's
one of my idols and I'm here to sing
that today now we're doing it in a
fantasy you're doing a Fantasy yes yes
okay are you ready give us a little
taste of the song yes I hope you
understand it
hit it
[Music]
can you do that part hi
I love it Viva Mexico
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]